there's there's pieces you can add
if you offer them it here
you're doing you're doing the wrong
you're doing the wrong technique
because it's natural if it's coming like
that it's downwards isn't it it's
downwards if he's coming here
then you've got a chance to all right so
what I found is
I'm so busy here that I get a little bit
stuck here it's a bit stuck now to get
this big lump through here so I'm not
very elegant of that so I need a little
more space so this is for the for the
hakama when he comes here I'm going to
push him to the stage without him
knowing it
to give it a bit more spice
it
it's not so much pushing him as it's
holding him off for from cat for this
arm coming inwards
so I go like that
and that's how I actually put a little
bit of that into it I'm not trying to
move it but I'm trying to do that I'm
trying to do that
you Coke you
ah
you can put Coke you in once you've got
it but you've got to but but this is uh
domineering and it could be a bullying
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to hold him off because I need
to so I don't know any of you are
finding that your body's too big to get
through the hole you're creating but if
you are that's what you you need to add
that little piece you know teachers
don't tell you this stuff because uh
they might not know you're struggling
with it
um if you train every day then I used to
do six days a week but
it it gets in being built uh
self-preservance
so but but you know I'm handing you here
do that don't think that oh I'll go
around it all and then you find oh this
is a bit difficult now I'll get him when
I get here no I'll do a Nico that'll
give him that'll tell him not to be so
difficult with me
so I'd like to uh
uh the the lady
yeah
and uh let's say
David he's big isn't he I stand there
please that's right I just need you to
stand there stand and David's stand
there
and
uh let's have a look uh
uh we'll use you your third Dan you
stand here okay so I want you to face
him as if you're going to now be his
ukis
all right so you ready to be a zookies
I'm now going to ask uh
a genuine question
and I'm asking you all the same question
who are you going to be more bothered
about
this one
let's face it we know don't we
and that's why you'll never be able to
do oh since I could die
because you've decided
who is going to give you the biggest
problem
if this person here thinks
I'll have to blend with either whatever
comes and if he genuinely genuinely
means that that I dare any of you do in
this room
we haven't found our senses Aikido yet
all right so you don't have to attack
him but that was a principle thank you
so so your biggest fault in what you're
trying to do in any of these techniques
is you're trying to
work the person out rather than blend
with what you've got
you see form can be a hindrance as well
as helpful
it doesn't matter who comes up like I
said I haven't trained with Dominic I
haven't trained with Roger it doesn't
matter to me
because I must
be polite to them
please go past I had a conversation a
moment a little while ago about a ton of
hanker wouldn't it be bad when on Keenan
Agave for them to do that so they can
take the rest
where here the wrist gets small and they
don't want to take it
and I said yes the problem with that is
let's have a look um let's see what the
problem is I'm on a line
in Keenan nagawe
in kihon I would go like this I would
get off the line I would turn and be
here
nagari you do this you get off the line
you turn there
but the point was but they haven't got a
lot of risk to grab
so if I go this way
they've got a better risk to grab
but if they do that way what happens is
as a teacher you start getting more
confident and you start doing that now
did I get out of the way of my partner
no
and it's because by doing that it makes
him naturally
go around me
okay so now I'm getting lazy yeah but
I'm good so I don't matter you know it
and this is a problem what happens with
teachers just because they can do it
they forget the basic principles the
base principles
I must do Tana henko the same with its
kinda nagari or kihon I must get out of
the way and say please go past I don't
want to fight you
so that's why if you work on linking
them together
linking them together
I the techniques all start looking the
same
it's the philosophy starts all becoming
the same
I get out his way on all of these
thank you
I mean I don't want to hit I don't want
to hit this big guy do I
you know I started to get out of the way
even to do it
I had to I had to get out of the way
even to perform it
but you will see some teachers who have
done karate and I could they would go
hey
you know they're not moving an inch
because they know they can go bang bang
why didn't he fall down
because I wasn't in his energy moving
I wasn't in his energy I had to keep
moving until he fell down
the stamina I'll go on till four o'clock
and those who want to go home thank you
and those who want to stay will be
working on throwing without touching and
we'll be working on energy work but out
of 100 people 99
uninterested so that's why I don't
really teach it all right but just
lately I've had more and more people
sort of pestering me to do it you can
see what I'm doing
he doesn't know why he's falling down
but we'll go into that but I don't want
to make it sound as if it's exotic or
special but those who are interested in
will say the energy
work it's a stepping stone to start it
am I doing it
I am Nick I become Nick
please go past
I'm a hundred percent
given to him what I'm not doing you can
use the yin and yang you can use the
dark side of this energy and go down
I will get it
I pulled him down because I wanted it to
work so there is a black side but if
you're a good person you'll overcome
that and your ego will realize it's not
the way to go through life and you're
and you'll do it
with love rather than hate or want
all right why does he keep falling down
I don't know what's wrong with him but
he should say a doctor
right so I tried it out on a 12 year old
Russian boy
he's like he was the best 12 year old
I've ever seen he I made him do a first
Q test it was superb I said do you want
to go another woman sort of study for it
30 minutes later he comes back he says
hi says yeah I'm ready
they speak English ready I thought 30
minutes you must be joking oh what but
it's on the it's on the YouTube you can
see his test I can't believe it 30
minutes and he'd worked out all I want
what I wanted
I done this on him and I said to him
please have a word with your mother when
you come home because you've got a
little bit of cotton here in and I said
that'd be a cotton
I said you shouldn't have it hanging so
after doing this a few times
he's going on
it's trying to see the cotton that I'm
pulling
so I it proved to me that uh because you
can't con children well I don't think
you can so it proved to me that I must
be I've worked something out correctly
you're not going to get there in a hurry
you're not going to get there while
you're trying to lift your arms you're
not going to get in there while you're
trying to do all this
it's only when the time is right
but if you want a stepping stone to
understanding of Senses Aikido
you need to do yoga because how Scentsy
done it
you need to meditate
you need to realize that it's not me me
me it's him him
and you should be hit to help everybody
I mean I know that if you was needed
somebody was out on the road and you saw
them fall off the bike or something most
of them would go out there I doubt if
anybody wouldn't go out there and say
are you okay all right so it's inbuilt
in US naturally